gavin newsom ahora tiene un respiro con
cerca del 70 de los votos contados
aventaja por mucho a sus rivales
republicanos
le dijimos si a terminar la pandemia al
derecho a votar sin miedo y sin falsos
fraudes o supresión de voto are water
prize y luís arias le dijimos si el
derecho constitucional de la mujer a
decidir por sí misma por soft
los republicanos habían convocado el
referendo revocatorio citando el manejo
de la pandemia del gobernador demócrata
pero el diverso grupo de rivales
conservadores que incluían a la estrella
de televisión cave línea nerd y al
anfitrión radial largo y helder perdiera
a mi oponente el gobernador gavin newsom
como an
aceptemos condecoró la derrota
[Aplausos]
the way
we may por cierto puede que hayamos
perdido la batalla pero ganaremos las
cosas con windows word
el mecanismo de revocatoria del estado
permite convocar elecciones haciendo una
petición así fue como el actor de
hollywood el republicano arnold
schwarzenegger llegó a ser gobernador en
históricamente california ha votado por
los candidatos demócratas a la
presidencia pero la revocatoria es un
llamado de atención para este partido
presidente joe by del respaldo al
gobernador al final de la campaña el
referendo revocatorio llegó cuando ambos
partidos se encaminan a las elecciones
de medio término de 2022 que
determinarán quién controla el congreso